( intro music )
Bob Poole:
Gorongosa National Park
sits right in the middle
of Mozambique.
In 1964 a long war
for independence
broke out against Portugal.
And that was followed by
an even longer civil war
that lasted until 1992.
The armies fed off the
wildlife in the park.
And by the time that
that war was over
there was almost
no animals left in the park.
It was left for dead.
But then,
about ten years ago
an international team,
led by this guy, Greg Carr
formed a partnership
with the Mozambican government
to start a 20-year project
to bring that park back.
When I arrived, in 2008,
Greg flew me around
and basically what I saw was
one great, huge, beautiful
African landscape.
I came down with my
Land Rover from Kenya.
And vehicles were in short
supply in the park.
So I ended up helping
people out, I...
I carried rangers around
and scientists and...
I spent more of my time going
around with people in the park
than I did actually filming.
And I loved it. It was great.
And I stayed.
And year after year kind
of went by and during that time
the wildlife started to rebound.
And I'm not kidding you
it was amazing how
quickly it came back.
Not all species,
but some species.
It was like,
it was staggering.
Everything had a baby.
I couldn't get enough of it.
And so,
the next thing I knew
I was officially joining a
team of scientists and rangers
on this great experiment to see
if we could bring Gorongosa
back to its former glory.
And to save it from all
of its new threats.
Poaching, illegal logging,
illegal mining
even settlements inside the park
and human-wildlife
conflict, outside the park
are all big problems
that the park faces.
But in Gorongosa
you've got Greg Carr
and a dedicated team of
scientists and rangers
that are working
hard to protect it.
And I believe it will survive.
I learned what it takes to fight
this fight for conservation.
It's perseverance.
When times got
tough in Gorongosa
I watched Greg Carr and his
team just put their head down
and work even harder
believing that one
day it would get better.
And it did.